Je suis illustrateur médical,
et j'ai un point de vue légèrement différent.
Je regarde, depuis tout petit,
les expressions de la vérité et de la beauté dans les arts
ainsi que dans les sciences.
Et alors que ce sont des choses magnifiques par leur propre fait --
il leur arrive également des choses magnifiques --
la vérité et la beauté comme idéaux qui peuvent être étudiés par les sciences
et par les maths sont presque comme la parfaite paire de jumelles à laquelle
un scientifique voudrait donner rendez-vous.
(Rires)
Ce sont des expressions de vérité comme des choses admirables,
dans le sens où ce sont des choses que vous pouvez vénérer.
Ce sont des idéaux qui sont puissants, qui sont irréductibles,
qui sont uniques, qui sont utiles --
parfois, souvent longtemps, après le fait lui-même.
Et vous pouvez envoyer quelques images à présent,
parce que je ne veux pas me voir à l'écran.
La vérité et la beauté sont des choses
qui sont souvent opaques pour des gens qui ne sont pas dans les sciences.
Ce sont des choses qui décrivent la beauté dans un sens
qui n'est souvent accessible que si vous comprenez le language
et la syntaxe de la personne
qui étudie le sujet dans lequel la vérité et la beauté s'expriment.
Si vous prenez les maths, E=mc au carré,
si vous prenez la constante cosmologique,
où il y a un idéal anthropique, où vous voyez que la vie a dû évoluer
par rapport aux nombres qui décrivent l'univers --
il y a des choses qui sont vraiment difficiles à comprendre.
Et ce que j'ai essayé de faire
depuis que j'ai eu ma formation en tant qu'illustrateur médical --
depuis que mon père m'a enseigné l'animation,
qui était sculpteur et mon mentor visuel --
j'ai voulu trouver un moyen d'aider les gens
à comprendre la vérité et la beauté dans les sciences biologiques
en utilisant l'animation, les images, en racontant des histoires.
Ainsi ces choses qui ne sont pas nécessairement évidentes pour les gens
peuvent être révélées, enseignées et comprises.
Les étudiants de nos jours sont souvent immergés dans un environnement
où ce qu'ils apprennent est susceptible de renfermer de la vérité et de la beauté
enfouies à l'intérieure, mais la façon dont elles sont enseignées est compartimentée
et amenée jusqu' à un point où la vérité et la beauté
ne sont pas toujours évidentes.
C'est presque comme cette vielle recette de soupe au poulet,
dans laquelle vous faites bouillir le poulet jusqu'à ce que le goût ait disparu.
Nous ne voulons pas faire ça à nos étudiants.
Donc nous avons une opportunité de réellement ouvrir l'éducation.
J'ai eu un coup de téléphone de Robert Lue d'Harvard,
au département de Biologie Moléculaire et Cellulaire,
il y a quelques années de cela. Il m'a demandé si mon équipe et moi
serions intéressés et voudrions vraiment changer
la façon d'enseigner la médecine et les sciences à Harvard.
Donc nous nous sommes embarqués dans un projet qui explorerait les cellules,
qui explorerait la vérité et la beauté inhérente
à la biologie moléculaire et cellulaire
ainsi les étudiants pourraient avoir une vision plus large
à laquelle ils pourraient relier tous ces faits.
Ils pourraient avoir une représentation mentale de la cellule
comme étant une grande ville, animée et terriblement compliquée
qui est habitée par des micro-machines.
Et ces micro-machines sont vraiment au coeur de la vie.
Ces micro-machines,
qui sont enviées par les nano-technologistes du monde entier,
sont autonomes, puissantes, précises, ce sont des appareils perfectionnés
qui sont fait de fils d'acides aminés.
C'est grâce à ces micro-machines que nos cellules bougent,
que nos cellules se répliquent, qu'elles font fonctionner nos coeurs,
qu'elles font fonctionner nos esprits.
Donc ce que nous avons voulu faire c'est de trouver
comment nous pourrions raconter cette histoire en animation
pour en faire la pièce maîtresse de BioVisions à Harvard,
qui est un site web d'Harvard destiné
aux étudiants en biologie moléculaire et cellulaire
qui va -- en association à toute l'information textuelle,
et de tous les outils didactiques --
réunir tout cela visuellement, pour que ces étudiants
puissent avoir une vision internalisée de ce qu'est vraiment une cellule
dans toute sa vérité et sa beauté, et soient en mesure d'étudier
avec cela en tête, que leurs imaginations soient en ébullition,
leurs passions brulantes
et ainsi qu'ils soient en mesure d'avancer
et d'utiliser ces visions dans leurs têtes pour faire de nouvelles découvertes
et soient en mesure de trouver, vraiment, comment la vie fonctionne.
Donc nous commençons par regarder comment ces molécules sont assemblées.
Nous travaillons avec un sujet, qui est, vous avez des macrophages
qui ruisellent le long d'un capillaire,
et ils touchent la surface de sa paroi,
et ils prennent des informations des cellules
qui sont sur la paroi du capillaire, et ils apprennent
qu'il y a une inflammation quelque part à l'extérieur,
où ils ne peuvent ni voir, ni sentir.
Mais ils reçoivent l'information qui les fait s'arrêter,
qui les fait internaliser qu'ils doivent faire
toutes les choses qui les font changer de forme,
et essayez de sortir de ces capillaires et trouver ce qu'il se passe.
Ainsi ces moteurs moléculaires -- nous avions à travailler
avec les scientifiques d'Harvad et des modèles de base de données
de molécules atomiquement précises
et comprendre comment ils bougeaient, et comprendre ce qu'ils faisaient.
Et trouver comment faire cela d'une façon
qui traduirait véritablement ce qui se passait,
sans que la foule compacte dans la cellule
empêche de voir l'événement.
Ce que je vais vous montrer ce sont 3 minutes
des premiers aspects du film de la version du Reader's Digest
que nous produisons. C'est un projet à venir
qui va prendre encore quatre ou cinq ans.
Et je veux que vous regardiez
et voyiez les chemins que la cellule crée --
ces petite machines mouvantes, qu'on appelle kinesines --
qui prennent ces gros chargements
qui rivaliseraient avec une fourmi à même échelle.
Envoyez le film, s'il vous plaît.
Mais ces machines qui font fonctionner l'intérieur des cellules
sont vraiment étonnantes, et sont vraiment la base de toute la vie.
Parce qu'elles interagissent toutes entre elles.
Elles se passent les informations;
elles entraînent différentes choses à l'intérieur de la cellule.
Et la cellule va alors créer les parties nécessaires
sur le moment, grâce à l'information
qui est apportée depuis le noyau par les molécules qui lisent les gênes.
Aucune vie, de la plus petite jusqu'à vous tous ici,
ne serait possible sans ces petites micro-machines.
En fait, ça aurait, en l'absence de ces machines,
rendu la salle plutôt vide, n'est ce pas Chris.
(Rires)
(Musique)
C'est le livreur FedEx de la cellule:
ce petit gars est appelé la kinésine,
et il tire un sac qui est plein de protéines tout juste fabriquées
jusqu'à l'endroit de la cellule qui en a besoin --
que ce soit vers une membrane, que ce soit vers une organelle,
que ce soit pour construire quelque chose ou pour réparer quelque chose.
Et chacun de nous a environ 100 000 de ces choses
courant partout, en ce moment,
à l'intérieur de chacune de nos mille milliards de cellules.
Donc peu importe à quel point vous vous sentez paresseux,
vous n'êtes intrinsèquement pas en train de ne rien faire.
(Rires)
Donc ce que je veux que vous fassiez en rentrant chez vous
c'est de penser à tout ça, de penser à quel point nos cellules sont puissantes,
et de penser aux choses
que nous sommes en train d'apprendre au sujet des mécaniques cellulaires.
Une fois que nous aurons compris tout ce qui se passe --
et croyez moi, nous connaissons à peine 1% de ce qui se passe --
donc une fois que nous aurons compris ce qui se passe,
nous serons capables d'avoir beaucoup de contrôle
au sujet de ce que nous faisons avec notre santé,
avec ce que nous faisons pour les générations futurs,
combien de temps nous allons vivre.
Et on peut espérer être capable de pouvoir utiliser cela
pour découvrir plus de vérité, et plus de beauté.
(Musique)
Mais c'est vraiment passionnant que ces cellules, ces micro-machines,
soient assez conscientes de ce dont à besoin la cellule pour offrir une réponse.
Elles travaillent ensemble; elles font faire à la cellule ce qu'il faut faire.
Et elles travaillent ensemble pour aider nos corps --
d'énormes entités qu'elles ne verront jamais -- à fonctionner correctement.
Je vous laisse apprécier la suite du show. Merci.
(Applaudissements)